on continue cette page au sport on va
avoir en liaison satellitaire mais oui
de tanguy de lamotte
bonsoir tanguy de lamotte voyez beaucoup
alors voilà bonsoir vous êtes que vous
êtes skipper et vous participez vous
êtes engagés sur le vendée globe alors
c'est je le rappelle c'est une course on
peut dire un peu folles autour du monde
avec trois caps à passer dont le fameux
cap de bonne espérance et on le
pitoyable impitoyable cap horn
vous êtes actuellement 12e vous êtes où
l'attend guy précisément vous allez me
dire je suis sur l'eau ça c'est normal
mais ou alors je suis à peu près par 38
degrés sud et 10 degrés ouest
approximativement et donc ça se trouve
un tout petit peu avant le cap de
bonne-espérance d'accord donc l'afrique
du sud de l'afrique du sud et je viens
de passer des villes qui s'appelle la
ville inaccessible a alors tu as bien
leur nom dans une bonne vision de qui
est il
je suis passé à quelques kilomètres de
fait il est très joli à voir
oui mais justement fait nous rêver dit
nous angoisser c'est très joli vous avez
quand même le temps de voir le paysage
mes affaires car justement qu'est pour
chaque matin c'était une belle matinée
de ce que je ne suis pas fait dans
l'article l'archipel de tristan da cunha
pas partir au brésil et du coup c'est
vrai que j'étais les premières faire que
je voyais depuis le que j'ai quitté les
côtes du portugal
donc ça fait plus de trois semaines je
l'avais vu que de l'eau et c'était très
agréable et les villes qui font que j'ai
et que j'ai vu de loin quand même le
fiston pas l'air très satisfaite
et voilà des jolies quand même d'avoir
quelque chose qui te refais de l'eau
justement tong il vous dit j'ai vu que
la mer depuis trois semaines vous êtes
parti depuis le 10 novembre
qu'est-ce qui est le plus dur quand on
est sur un bateau est ce que c'est la
solitude
est-ce que c'est d'affronter la nuit
évidemment les conditions climatiques
non moi je fais parce que j'aime ça donc
je dépeins parce que je suis tout seul
que j'aime que j'aime faire du bateau je
vais faire du bateau j'aime voyager leur
accès non il ya des moments parfois il
ya des moments où il faut il faut se
dépasser ses limites et pour régler des
problèmes qui seront à bord quand mon
père ou du mal plus que je dû faire
vendredi dernier et puis par contre
c'est vrai que là il ya des choses
exceptionnelles comme comme pas prêts au
large du brésil là que je vous reverrai
jamais dans ma vie
peut-être effectivement et voilà préfère
mélange de tout ça après que et
accueillons mais ils peuvent quand même
pas mal de choses dans la journée et un
grand voyage en bateau
alors je continue parce que moi ça m'a
fait complètement rêver votre votre
aventure puis c'est la première fois
plus que vous faites le tour du monde
un souvenir paris d'une image je sais
pas vous voyez des dauphins samedi
arnaud n'y en a pas des dauphins dans ce
coin là bas alors difficile et il aurait
vendu des dauphins cette fois ci j'en ai
pas vu que général on en voit même en
mer au large des côtes françaises on en
voit régulièrement près de lorient diaby
est donc là je fais bien de lui donc
j'ai pas réussi à les voir des buts
entendu sinon leila tabanou qui me
suivront des 1 va tromper
et sinon j'ai vu quelques petits doigts
d'offenbourg du chemin y en a pas qui se
sont arrêtés à bord mais de temps en
temps ils sont fatigués donc ils
s'arrêtent reprendre des forces et puis
sinon j'ai vu pas mal de poisson volant
puisque quand on passe dans les zones
chaudes il ya beaucoup de poissons
volants donc fait des poissons est
extraordinaire qui sortent de l'ombre
qui prend qui vont faire manger par par
rapport au plafond et mon bateau
en fait les vols il vole au dessus de
l'eau pendant quelques secondes
depuis c'est pas mal quand même
grâce donc ça ce sont vos compagnons de
voyage et comment comment vous allez si
nous est serein tout va bien à bord jeu
là on attaque la partie sérieuse et
peut-être plus difficile de la course le
tour de l'autre de l'antarctique avec
l'océan indien et l'océan pacifique
donc on commence à aller un peu plus
vite il commence à faire un peu plus
froid donc là j'ai sorti des polaires
mais tout va bien j'ai préparé le bateau
pour ces conditions là et le bateau est
à 100% de ce pack forme et donc moi
aussi les batteries chargées à bloc et
fils maintenant j'ai vraiment envie
d'aller découvrir ces paysages éphémères
inconnu pour voir ce que sur internet on
vous a vu danser sur le pont de votre
bateau soit qu'on va voir quelques
images cependant nous de raconter ça
vous dansez vous aimez danser avec cette
citation pour nos téléspectateurs l'a
promis c'est véronique et davina pour la
tester le jeu ça vous avez le moral en
clarifiant de gym a profité mardi matin
qui m'a fait revivre d'échauffement
avant de monter dans le mât c'est vrai
que ben on est tout seul donc on ya des
moments on a besoin d'eux on a besoin de
s'exprimer de faire un petit délire
voilà il faut que la fête est tombée sur
cette musique et ça m'a donné cette
envie c'était le jour où je me suis rasé
donc dû me suis fait il nous quitte h
spécial kevin kim
et puis vous sachez qu'en est il
exactement
pour revenir aux sur le plan pour
sportifs alors quelle a été votre option
à vous est ce que vous avez suivi les
côtes africaines côtes africaines où
êtes vous êtes parti de plus à l'ouest
pour arriver au cap de bonne espérance
alors pour le pour la fin de la ville
centre pour la fin de la descente de
l'atlantique
tout le monde est obligé de taper
alouettes peuvent que le long des côtes
africaines en fait il ya pas de vent il
ya l'anticyclone de sainte hélène
mais un peu comme l'antique l'icône d
abord en mixte erner et si on va trop
près de la côte est de l'afrique qui
atteint raconte qu'il y aura mon chemin
mais par contre y'a pas de vendre en
avant 3 comme tout le monde c'est un peu
le grand tour et donc on veut tout sauf
du côté du brésil et puis là on est tous
en train
les premiers font déjà partie à bonne
espérance de tino on va passer dans dans
24 heures ou 36 heures
quand vous dites les premiers c'est jean
pierre dick ou le cléac'h et j'ai envie
de vous demander à moi aussi quand on
voit des skippers comme vincent riou par
exemple ou samantha davies qui ont
abandonné
on pense quoi quand on s'appelle tanguy
de lamotte confessons premier tour de
monde on est fier d'être toujours en
course où on se dit j'ai eu là j'ai de
la chance on va faire mélange des deux
futurs qu' il ya une partie de chance
dans ce corps là il faut il faut avoir
on sort déjà il faut attaquer tout le
monde n'y arrive pas il faut avoir un
bateau et est ensuite il faut avoir un
peu de réussite pour aurait fait encore
sauf que quelques courses extrêmement
longue durée et donc l'endurance et
varié qui est mécanique sur le bateau il
y en a beaucoup
yamaha qui peuvent café pour une raison
x ou y qu'on a on peut pas du tout
contrôle et donc
ou alors comme vincent riou avoir une
collision avec un objet flottant qui est
complètement incontrôlable donc moi je
les classe de faire tout ce qui est en
mon possible pour que la course passe
bien et que j'abandonne pas par une
faute de ma part
pour l'instant je laisse après qu'ils
soient éliminatoires on va dire mais
j'ai aussi une lampe de chance qu'il n'y
ait pas eu autre chose qu'il soit tombé
dessus dont c'est vrai que c'est pour ça
mon objectif c'est déjà de la finir et
pas forcément l'utilité de la gagner
donc je fais la même rythme que les
premiers et qui prennent un peu figure
hic pour essayer de gagner et si cas
quitte à abandonner un peu trop fort une
dernière session tanguy de lamotte vous
courez sur initiative coeur en lien avec
mécénat chirurgie cardiaque alors un mot
rapide sur cet engagement je crois aussi
qu à des dessins des enfants qui orne
votre bateau l'intérieur du bateau oui
alors il ya effectivement des femmes des
enfants qui découvrent l'intérieur de
mon bateau est le vrai objectif de
l'initiative coeur point fr donc créé un
site rds qui porte le nom de la
fondation du conte d'action peut être
est créée par mon sort donc à toutes les
initiatives et à chaque fois que
quelqu'un vienne cliquez sur se fixe
donc initiative
tirez coeur point fr et montrons
s'engage à donner un euro à
l'association pour opérer les enfants et
pour l'instant depuis le début de
l'opération on a on a opéré on a pu
opérer trois enfants donc on a récupéré
plus de 36000 glisse et donc sans
difficulté 36000 euros et à l'opération
d'un enfant c'est dix mille euros dont
qu'on a on a encore le compteur si tôt
mais on en fait ma course continue et 20
janvier j'encourage tout le monde à
aller cliquer sur le site internet et
est pour nous aider à pouvoir
calorifique franck et qu'on a déjà fait
quatre ans qu'on n'a pas de limite
supérieure et que allemand au rythme où
on va on va pouvoir en opéré du coeur et
le message est passé et donc initiative
tirer coeur point fr si on veut cliquer
et amener de l'argent supplémentaire
pour mécénat chirurgie cardiaque
merci tanguy de lamotte merci beaucoup
d'avoir répondu à nos questions
et bah oui ça coûte 5 août du coeur il
faut donner son coeur bonne bonne chance
en tout cas pour votre fin de course
j'ai envie de vous dire bon vent dans
les quarantièmes rugissants et puis vous
savez qu on vous suit de très près à la
rédaction il ya des journalistes qui
sont férus de voile et qui nous suivent
de très près donc on vous souhaite
vraiment bonne chance et vous viendrez
fin janvier nous raconter votre aventure
sur notre plateau oui je reviendrai par
téléphone et ben oui on sera ravi de
vous recevoir
bonne chance tanguy à bientôt voilà et
on poursuit cette suite avec une page
environnement